ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show and happy halloween
uh we're here with uh chief vaping
silence and he is the chief
and he's it ben is actually dressed as
a as a proud indian chief who
was very pro-colonist
and there are this is not written about
but many
of the uh indian chiefs love the
colonists
and um ben is is dressed up after that
chief who said our way of life
is valid however
progress is what it is
and you know and he
he started the uh
it's uh the native am america exit the
native americas
exit the native american the native
american
were like blexit candace owens you did
blexits you did
native amer it's hard
it's very difficult
this is just something that we didn't
use for sketch we bought it we had it i
threw it on
is everyone ready for election day
it's election day in america board up
the stores and get a gun
board up the stores and get a gun it's a
healthy
democracy we've boarded up all the
stores
all the glass that can be smashed is now
behind
wood that's how you know we're doing
good
walmart has stopped selling guns in
ammunition
but they're still selling liquor just
booze it up
trump or biden booze it up high
spaghettios booze it up
don't ask about your job don't ask about
your health insurance
don't ask why your kids are on drugs
don't ask about the vaccine just
put the needle in your ass don't
question us
and we won't have to kill you or make
things so bad
that you kill yourself
what a week
i did one of the biggest podcasts ever
recorded and i sat next
love him or hate him i sat one next to
one of the most fascinating people
ever little zan and and that was such a
meaningful event in my life to be part
of that podcast
to sit there and and and
and do some time with the thinker
i am i am of course being
silly the podcast i'm talking about was
the one with joe rogan and alex jones
may be one of the best podcasts ever
recorded
not because of me i was funny but
what a great podcast of course
love or hate alex jones he's the most
entertaining person on the planet
um in terms of skill as a broadcaster he
it's beyond anything
i've ever seen up close in person it's
truly amazing
and i i had some really good funny
moments and
and joe did a great job everyone's mad
at the fact checking it's like joe's got
to do that
because that's what makes a good
listening experience
even though some of you are angry at it
i get i understand what you're saying
but when joe's like let's slow down and
look at these things
and alex ends up getting proven right
right
that's literally what differentiates
that podcast from something where you
let alex rant and then the people go
well [ __ ] that it's all wrong
can't say that about this podcast
because we have
the receipts and joe was like going
through every story with him so that was
that was really interesting to do and um
i'm happy i did it and then i'm back
with joe and kyle kuklinski for the
election special
on november 2nd
election day a lot of people have
already voted more than half of the
country
has already voted or something like that
is it could that be a real statistic
who are these people doing early voting
i think a large percentage of the
electorate has already cast a ballot
it's shocking to me
so more than 80 million americans it
looks like more than 80 million
americans have already voted in the
presidential election and 50 million of
those people have boarded up their homes
and isn't that nice
i'm telling you this what it really
i mean could anything
be more of an omen for
this country than walmart stop
they had to stop selling guns out of
fear
of what's coming could anything
be more perfect than walmart saying you
can't come on down here
to get socks and ammunition you
gotta relax walmart returns
returns guns and ammo to store floors
saying civil unrest was isolated oh
so they did it for like two days and
then oh they're back they're back
what am i saying thank the lord
walmart on friday said it's returning
guns and ammunition to store floors
describing incidents of what the
retailer called civil unrest and several
of its stores earlier this week as
isolated
hey that's only a few cities
only a few of our locations have been
completely destroyed get the guns back
out
i like that attitude hey get the guns
what are you doing some you know some
guy walked in a walmart
there's like a bunch of people carrying
crates of ammunition some manager goes
hey what the [ __ ] going on
didn't you hear we got word from up top
get the bullets back out on the shelves
they go well i just spoke to someone in
in the philadelphia store who just got
stamped to death they said hey isolated
incident dummy
haven't you heard that person had
children that got trampled to death it's
isolated
we don't expect it to happen here so put
the guns back out
next to the waffle irons and everybody
get ready major cities are boarding up
their storefronts just in case people
have a little fun on election day
major
preparation is underway for
boarded up windows and increased
security retailers brace for the
election there's that rodeo drive
oh yeah it is that's rodeo drive in
sunny california
nordstrom the high-end department store
chain said it planned to board up some
of its 350 stores
and hire extra security for election day
tiffany and company
the luxury jeweler said that windows of
select stores in key cities will be
boarded up in anticipation of potential
election related activity
isn't that a fun way to say it well
there is potential election related
activity
that could look like bricks through our
windows
in beverly hills the police said they
would take a proactive approach and
close rodeo drive
a renowned strip of luxury retailers on
tuesday and wednesday
citing the likelihood of protest
activity quote
quote unquote protest activity
the police working with private security
companies cia massa
mi6 said they would also be on full
alert throughout beverly hills starting
on halloween and continuing
what is halloween going to be this year
what is it going to be we've got
socially distanced trick-or-treating
what are you going to be doing how are
you going to do this
what are the guidelines what is because
kovitz back baby
i don't know if you know this but kovitz
back we're gonna have to reschedule some
of our comedy shows my fans are gonna
get mad at me
here's why we're gonna have to do that i
don't know which ones yet here's
why comedy is fun when they let people
in the building you see it's kind of a
requirement
when they decrease the amount of people
you can have in by hundreds of people
you go this isn't fun i want to come
back when we're big and we can do it big
we've had great shows in dallas and fort
worth in nashville and west palm
and tampa phenomenal shows san antonio
and those rooms have been packed i mean
they've been coveted festivals
nobody's got a mask i mean it's been the
good old days you know
the good old days of uh you know me
going up there
killing for an hour and then people on
youtube going i don't whatever
and the good old days but it's been
great dan's
opening for me he's been killing we've
been having an amazing time we can't do
the meet and greets after people get mad
at me they get angry they're like
stop that way or not i can't because
then
the rats and there are rats they find
these photos and go
he's doing meet and greets close this
club down because they're miserable
people
so i'm trying to protect the interests
of the club and myself
i don't want to get sick more
importantly i don't want a fan getting
sick i don't want
and i don't want the club having to deal
with bad press and [ __ ]
these places have not been open they're
trying to make [ __ ] money
but the problem with a lot of these uh
things now is that the cases are spiking
so the clubs are coming back and going
okay
we're getting all these increased
regulations and we're gonna have to do a
certain percentage of people
that to me is not fun i'd rather wait a
month or two and go back out on the
roadway
it was my rationale in the beginning i
want comedy to be
fun for everyone involved we've got 90
000 corona cases in 24 hours for the
first time
which is a record it's a resurgence of
covert 19
covet 19 is back
covent is back baby you just see bill
and melinda gates like
somebody's watching me you know
it's like 90 000 cases just them and
fauci just dancing in one of his nine
mansions
you know like 90 000 baby
it's back baby with event now i don't
know what this thing is i don't know if
i've had it i've
had it for 10 years i'm gonna get it
i'm gonna die i don't know what it is
i've been exposed to it probably i've
been out we've been out i've been in
clubs
i mean we've been careful i've been in
planes i put on masks i don't even know
anymore
no one knows it's just back and it's big
it's bigger than ever
it's covered two it's a summer
blockbuster
coven is back that's right
just in time for the holidays it'll be
like a movie you know
just in time for the holidays kovit is
back and better than ever
national lampoon's covered christmas
i don't know what's gonna happen i'm
just saying we're gonna have to move
some of these dates to the under
the other end of whatever this is
hopefully it's february march
we can kind of get into those markets
and and and play
to rooms full of people not
a hundred people socially distanced in a
room of 400.
that to me is not fun and you know and i
love everybody that buy tickets
it's [ __ ] we've had an amazing time
west palm beach was some of the most fun
i've had doing stand-up
i mean drunk monstrous crowds horrible
people like myself
that's when i know i'm having fun when i
go look in the audience and i go these
are
bad people and that's why they enjoy me
because i'm a bad bird
and it works sometimes i look at a crowd
and i go ugh
they're not going to want to laugh west
palms great
you're the ocean the mansions the human
trafficking in the middle of one of the
shows i'm [ __ ] on jesus maxwell she
stood up
and started a wave and the whole room
did it
that's the type of [ __ ] i want that's
the type of fun i want you know
are kids allowed to trick-or-treat bring
something up about that are they allowed
if the kid shows up at my house
trick-or-treating i'm gonna
sit that youngster down and tell them
about civic duty
i'd say what is wrong with you don't you
know
0.0001 percent of people die of this
so we're on the cdc's website we're on
the cdc's website here we go
steps to take when trick-or-treating
avoid direct contact
with trick-or-treaters so if your son
sees his friend
make sure they go nowhere near each
other
trick-or-treating should be an isolated
activity
it should be isolated and scary
give give out treats outdoors if
possible
isn't that always how it's been right
who's trick-or-treating
what pedophile is going you want candy
come on in the living room
isn't it always an outdoor thing isn't
it always a doorstep thing
it always is what weird epstein type is
going
the real candies in the kitchen
set up a station with individually
bagged treats for kids to take
okay that always works out well some
fatty
goes and steals them all wash hands
before handing treats and finally wear
a mask well it's halloween that
shouldn't be that hard
make your cloth mask part of your
costume
fun fun a costume mask is not a
substitute for a cloth mask
mask should not be worn by children
under the age of two or anyone who has
trouble breathing
wait a minute hold on
hold on we're gonna let a bunch of
one-year-olds
not be masked up i think not
stay at least six feet away from others
who do not live with you
yeah most people don't live with you use
bring hand sanitizer with you and use it
after touching objects or other people
parents supervise young children using
hand sanitizer how great would it be if
a bunch of young
hooligans went out and instead of
toilet papering cars and throwing eggs
this year
just started blasting hand sanitizer all
over things
how about this year instead of toilet
paper you just see masks
hanging from trees and houses remember
that did you ever get into trouble on
halloween all hallows eve yeah teepeeing
teepeeing where you throw the
the toilet paper rolls and that was a
real because your family didn't have a
lot of that
so that was a real thing for you to do
yeah
can you take that off now we've had fun
with the costumes please
it's bothering me can you take this off
what are you he wore that to
what are you in full regalia here he got
excited about the
costume the love of god my culture is
not your costume
don't disrespect the mayans who used to
sacrifice children on a mountain
the minds didn't dress like that i know
what's going on folks
i'm incredibly intelligent many people
are shocked by that
i i used to i remember eighth grade i i
said this is the time to be
cool there are times in your life when
you should be cool
many of you have never been cool how sad
is that
being cool is destroying property like
antifa
if if i was a kid right now i'd be an
antifa because it's cool
that's what i'd be you know
i'd be in i'd be like fat antifa
which is the saddest antifa where it's
like you're
you're like heavily breathing everybody
else is really getting in the riding
you're kind of in the back
you know you just have a lot of fun
things to say about karl marx but like
dude you weren't even there you're like
oh
i was there dude you didn't even do
anything we all got arrested
you didn't even run up the hill you sat
down
you sat down in all black no
i would provide the intellectual fire
me and ray comp are going to do a great
sketch called fat antifa
where it's two guys that were on their
way to charlottesville to fight
the right wing people but they kept
getting distracted
by fast food restaurants and then
and they kept eating and then eventually
they were just beaten to a bloody pulp
by a female trump supporter
in like a golden corral parking lot we
never did it
but i remembered 8th grade it was like
it's time to be cool so the cool guys at
my school they had names like johnny and
alfred
we went to [ __ ] be cool and throw
eggs and hang out in the park and
shaving cream things
and that was cool and i wish that for
all of you i hope you have a journey
that involves a
night like that where you can be cool
and hang out with people like johnny and
alfred and
throw eggs and do shaving cream and then
i went to my
i after that night i went at the end of
that night when my dad was eating dinner
at a steakhouse the steakhouse in the
town i grew up in and i came and i
smelled like shaving cream but i said it
was cologne
and my father's friend who owned the
steakhouse was like ah you got the
cologne on for the girls i was like yep
that's exactly right that's exactly
right
little do you know i've been sucking
dick in the bushes i was
not i was not i was not doing that
i was throwing eggs and doing shaving
cream so i i hope there's a way for
kids to vandalize safely
you can't even be against vandalism
anymore as long as you just say well
it's
uh it's political right political so if
you're a kid
and you're leaving your house with two
dozen eggs
and your parents go what are you doing
you turn around and say
shut up you capitalist pig and shut the
door
they can't say [ __ ] to you be like oh
what am i doing uh it's
called a revolution how about you
keep watching how i met your mother okay
and yes i will have leftovers leave them
in the fridge
but i'm gonna do out go out and do
revolution with my friends
be with my friends so much of this sad
shitty life we all live is social once
you realize that you realize that
there's
there's no hope in ideas everybody wants
to just get hugged
there's no hope and ideas dummy
i'm going out with my friends to burn
down the courthouse
i have friends too it's a [ __ ] so
everybody's a [ __ ] social these maga
hat [ __ ] since so
they're driving around in cadillac see
you know they're are you on the team i'm
on the team we got something to do
so much of this pitiful miserable
experience of life
is just finding people to [ __ ] and
tolerate you
that's it this this is all
thing i remember that you don't get
smarter than when you're in eighth grade
and you go i want to throw eggs with the
cool cake you're just
everybody wants to throw eggs with the
cool kids you just want to get invited
you want to have value you want to have
worth shut up
stop being bigger and better than
everything you just want to shave and
cream someone's car with johnny and
alfred
that's what you want to do now whatever
that version of that is
playing golf and having a 401k who cares
same [ __ ] it's all social we're social
creatures nobody's really an island
some people very few the majority of us
are
organisms that need others in validation
constantly and
i love halloween i've always liked
halloween i like it because
it's about simulated
horror and i think simulated horror
is a nice way to get away from
actual horror with actual horror happens
from uh november 1st
all the way to october 30th and then one
day
everyone goes let's pretend that we're
scared
let's find things to scare us boo
like haunted houses and scary movies
but the other 364 days are filled with
very
real verifiable accounts of nightmarish
behavior
that by the very grace of god and sheer
luck you don't find yourself embroiled
in
it's hard to enjoy movies like hostile
because i i used to think they were fake
i can't enjoy them anymore as much
because i guarantee you
there is a place in bratislava where you
can take a drill
and go through some taurus eye and if
there isn't
there should be because if there's not
you're leaving a lot of money on the
goddamn table
you can't enjoy texas chainsaw i'm
asking her anymore
why because now you don't see leather
face as someone scary
you see him as somebody that runs for
the senate
how can you enjoy a horror film it's
better any
jason freddy krueg these people are all
better than the people who run the
country
they've all done less killing
they've all done less killing than our
leaders how do you enjoy a horror movie
house of a thousand corpses how nice it
would be if there were only a thousand
corpses
do you know how many of these third
world countries would go you only killed
a thousand of us
they'd be dancing in the street with
american flags on right now
a thousand corpses is tuesday morning
before you have [ __ ] lunch how can
you enjoy a horror movie now it's hard
it's difficult when you know the actual
[ __ ] that goes on
if leatherface was around today he'd be
running
a a major facebook q and on account that
just got
shut down and he'd come out and say they
shouldn't have shut me down and i kind
of agree with leatherface i think he's
got crazy ideas but i agree with
leatherface
and then he'd mount a campaign for you
know local congress or something
hold your watch up look at this watch
look how nice that watch looks
that is a hot watch just black black and
gold
i'll tell you right now show that watch
off
look at that watch
put it away now now let me create the
moment with words
i am partnering with vincero watches and
we could not be more excited finding a
watch that's stylish bold and built to
last can be a pretty penny
ventura watchers is changing that
they believe you deserve to look good
and feel good no matter your budget
ventura creates exceptionally crafted
watches and they do it without breaking
the bank the guys on their team sent me
some of the watches let me tell you
they're stunning
they're offering you 20 off your entire
order if you go to venturawatches.com i
got to be honest these are beautiful
it's a beautiful timepiece you can
remember the time where
look at what was the time when the civil
war started
these watches are bold fine looking
they're a perfect conversation starter
you're sitting at the bar you see a
attractive lady or gentleman and you go
hey
you know what i like to do like you know
how i like to start a conversation i go
look at my watch
look at my watch let's do it we're on a
date right now okay i've got a
uh vincero vincero vincero
i go this is how i would start if we're
having a date
okay not a date we're at a bar okay you
know what i mean gotcha
i'm a zero red-blooded american male and
you're a beautiful woman
okay ready hey look at my watch
wow that's really nice it's a vincetto
watch look at it wow it's a nice you
want to take a photo of it
no i'm good i think this watch is
stylish and bold wouldn't you say i
guess yeah it's a nice watch man
it is a nice watch it's a beautiful
watch
it's got over 23 000 five star reviews
on their website
go and read for them yourself
what are you doing in town oh uh
there's a conference keep looking at it
oh please keep looking at it while you
speak
um it's a uh i'm in a town for a
conference it's a
dentist it's a dentist conference we're
all getting together for the
do i have to keep looking at the watch i
would prefer it yes
we're staying at the hotel downtown
we're staying at the ace
and um this is making me really
uncomfortable that i just have to
keep it's only making you uncomfortable
because you don't have a venture
i have more watchers in my hotel room
would you like to go and see them
yeah see works
that's the way she said yeah yeah
they're offering free shipping free
returns for 30 days a warranty on your
watch for up to
two years that's pretty wild stress-free
shopping right from home i'm telling go
to venturawatches.com
these are really nice i love the one
that you have
they are spectacular watchers so get one
right now so go to vincero watches
v i n c e r o w
a t c h e s vincero watches dot com
slash tim you get twenty percent you're
all
20 off your order it is a great gift not
only for yourself but it is a phenomenal
gift
for another family member and we're
heading into the holiday season
so do it now have the watches now don't
be scrambling and waiting
when we hit december everybody's gonna
go crazy do it now
buy it now it's a great way to get a
great watch and support
this show everybody's starting a
business and they're all online you
can't leave your house you're not
allowed cove it's skyrocketing we've got
94 000 cases just today so the smartest
thing for you to do
is start an e-commerce business online
how are you going to ship stuff you
don't know what the hell you're doing
you fool
if you did you would have been done that
already but you didn't so if you go to
shipstation.com
shipstation.com is the fastest easiest
most affordable way to manage and ship
your orders
and a few clicks you're managing orders
printing out discounted shipping labels
and getting your products out fast the
result
happier holidays for you and your
customers i don't care what you sell
junk from the attic art that you make in
a mental institution whatever it is
put it out there and get it sold
you need somebody to handle all the back
office shipstation.com handles all the
back office you get that
you spend your time being the
entrepreneur the ceo the creator
ship station handles the orders the
tracking they track
the orders they offer big discounts on
shipping costs now any business can
access the same postage
discounts that are usually reserved for
fortune 500 companies
you'll always know that you're getting
the best deal and my favorite thing
about this offer is
how many months do they get free 60 days
60 days
two free months if you're an
entrepreneur you're starting your
business or even if you've had a
business
60 days of free cost is amazing i'm
telling you right now it's very
important
it's very important that you do this
you got to start an e-commerce business
nobody is immune
uh to the coming economic collapse the
only people that are going to be okay is
if you're making your money online you
got to make it online you got a
ship so if you go to the tim dillon show
listeners can try ship station free for
60 days when you offer the code tim
dillon my name the code tim dillon you
go to shipstation.com today
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in tim dillon
that shipstation.com
and enter the code tim dillon ship
station make ship
happen and you can and will and i'm
telling you this is the best way
i have friends that have e-commerce
businesses uh this is the way to do it
what are your favorite scary movies
favorite
halloween movies favorite halloween
movie
uh off the top of my head hocus pocus
because i watched it when i was a kid
very gay hocus pocus now ben is a wife
and i i hope she's not in therapy
in years from now hocus pocus is a gay
iconic movie i like it it's very gay
it's
it's a bette midler and uh i'm aware
it's kathy najimy
similarities who's brilliant and uh
sarah jessica parker and it's a very gay
funny movie and i i enjoy that too it's
not really a horror movie
right uh favorite it's scary
here's why hocus pocus is legitimately
scary
everybody in the movie is white
that's terrifies me that they would have
such a lack of concern
for diverse was there one disabled
person
was there one person going through a
transition in the film
no thank you was there one black panther
in the movie no no
no good i like a movie called jacob's
ladder with uh tim robbins and
the guy yeah yeah phenomenal film and
danny aiello
great someone said and they were right
they were like danny aiello's face
is is on in every pizzeria in manhattan
if you've ever been in new york the
celebrity like pizzeria has put the
celebrities that have eaten there
on the wall and danny aiello is in like
more of them than anyone else this is uh
oh my god does he look bad he looks oh
jesus
is he still alive i like danny aiello
no he died in december 12 2019 sad
he's great well anyway
yeah jacob's ladder yeah great yeah and
it's about a guy that with the vietnam
and this is why i like it because
there's a little bit of a backstory
it was about a guy that went to vietnam
and the government
experimented very similar to agent
orange they experimented with this drug
called the latter which made
uh american servicemen more vicious
and they in the movie they explained
that we were we were
not convinced that we could win vietnam
because our boys were soft
we needed them to be more vicious so we
needed to unlock
the real nightmares inside of them and
they they all took the struggle the
latter
it's a cool movie and many of you may
enjoy it and then
i think at the end danny aiello's like
there's there's this great quote in it
that i like
danny aiello demons quote jacob's ladder
demons quote
demons and angels quote it's kind of a
fun little quote
demons are really angels yeah that's the
quote this is a fun movie by the way
many couples i see many couples come out
to the shows and i like that i like that
my fan base is
primarily heterosexual but at least many
of them are coupled up it's good to do
something every night and not have one
person that potentially will like me
ever
so i enjoy that it's nice you know
straight guys do comedy
people message them hey it was great you
wanna have a dr you know what i mean
people message me hey
look at this pizza menu in omaha do you
think the s is really uh
jacob this is a quote i like if you're
afraid of dying and you're holding on
you'll see devil's tearing your life
away but if you've made your peace then
the devils are really angels freeing you
from the world
it all depends on how you look at it but
danny aiello does the quote
so danielle is like if you made a piece
the devil's really angels
free you from the world he's got garlic
not falling out of his mouth
it all depends on how you look at it
you see
i enjoy that film i like a lot of the
rob zombie movies devils rejects
which is a movie about comedians
i'm kidding house of a thousand corpses
so by the way after i did the rogan
episode i
you know how much i love
and and value journalists
because they write about our world
and it's so important and many of the
a few articles are written about me
who's this tim doe
he says he sold subprime mortgages and
his mothers are schizophrenic
it's like the the level of research they
do is like nothing it's like
yeah that's in a five-minute set you can
find online well done
um and so and then some of them are like
he's made
controversial comments and by the way
these aren't journalists let me correct
myself
there's like seven journalists in
america that's why everyone's like trump
hates journalists there
are no journal they don't exist
they're not real they're like santy
claus
they're not a thing okay there's a few
of them
very few of them who actually cultivate
sources
break story they did not happen the
majority
of these people are stenographers they
write things they hear they hear gangnam
and then they type it and they write
listicles and buzzfeed
one of them was like the top 10 craziest
things you hear from the rogan alex
jones
this is not journalism it is
something else entirely um and then of
course there are and this is very very
funny
people who put the words comedy and
journalist in one job title
i'm a comedy journalist my
beat is people that make
sillies i write about them
and some of these people like they'll be
like tim dillon's made
controversial statements about the
kenosha
shooting the kyle rittenhouse and the
and none of
and then i read what's supposedly
controversial
and it's like tim dillon said there was
looting and right and it's like
no objective reality
has said that
i have repeated it because i have ears
and eyes and senses
and i don't go at it with like the need
to slant i just go
i'm watching tv i'm watching things
burn i'm watching people
throw things through windows what would
i
call that if i had to describe and
whatever it is what it is fine when i
[ __ ] i'm not saying people shouldn't
be pissed i get it
you know but this idea that like i uh oh
your car has made some controversy and
the controversial statement i saw was
that the
the written house guy was being chased i
was being chased i think somebody and
somebody had a gun or whatever like and
again i saw the video i saw the video i
said what i saw in the video
and then they take all these things out
of context that are very very funny
i made some very funny statements about
that very very funny about the family
you know the written houses
i said they're a bit off and they're
like he's sad they're a bit
like it's it's it's clearly humor and
these people don't have a sense of humor
all these tech journalists these tech
journalists these women or
not sorry sorry sorry these entities
with you know green hair and a usb port
for a [ __ ]
are are you know these miserable
people they're miserable they're unhappy
they're unhappy and it's my fault it's
my fault you're
miserable and they were and then i look
and twitter many of them have blocked me
they've already blocked me and i'm like
what am i
what did i do what did i do did i shoot
anyone
did i go to the protest with the gun
with my mother
i don't just see my family during good
times i didn't grab my family and say
let's all get in the van go to the
protest
i'm commentating on it tim dylan get it
up here get up
google me and say let's get this article
up it's it's absurd
tim dillon made uh do google tim dillon
kenosha
how great is how fun is my life because
yeah go to me what is this meow is it
meow
i guess this is the one joe rogan puts
alex jones tim dillon on his podcast
internet angry he featured anti-vaxxer
during pandemic keep going down
and then
control f here yeah and then they
but who is tim dillon he owns a podcast
called tim dolan's going to hell
that has not been the name of the
podcast for years some of his comments
during the black lives matter protest
have received sharp criticism
from who case in point in the aftermath
of the shooting in kenosha wisconsin in
late august
commenting on armed civilians tylon had
said quote when the police are defunded
abolish this will be the scene in many
major cities militias finding each other
on the street
well what do you think the scene will be
compliance do you think everybody i mean
what
i mean how dumb are these people so keep
going down then they find a tweet
where i say a logical rational thing
so with these two guests on board it is
only likely that people will criticize
rogue's decision to host them
one twitter user said wtf is wrong with
him
oh there was a time years ago and his
podcast had some interesting
thought-provoking episodes now it's just
crazy town
oh it wasn't thought-provoking aren't
you having thoughts right now
aren't you having thoughts it's not
thought provoking you went on twitter
and started writing about it apparently
you were provoked
and you were having thoughts come on
it's there's there's there's a children
in the country
i mean we don't deserve a government or
our future and we and here's the good
news we probably won't have one
um it's it's childish
we can officially count his show among
the most dangerous propaganda outlets in
the guy
by the way guarantee that person has a
podcast it's not doing well
anyone that's really mad at this let's
let's really unpack the problem
by the way all of these people are
have to here's it let's break this down
for a minute you know i never talk about
comedy but let me get in here for a
minute
let me get in here for a minute comedy
is a haven for the mentally ill
there is actually very little comedy the
majority of comedy and comedians
are are mentally ill people they're sick
including me the difference is that i'm
funny
you see if i was sick and not
funny i'd be angry because they'd be
like well i'm
sick and i'm not funny like i have these
obsessions and i'm crazy and everybody
knows
bloody blue and and i talk about all
this [ __ ]
and and it's funny and i find a way to
make it funny and that's how i survive
on this planet right
but if i didn't have the converter if i
wasn't able to make it funny a la many
of the people i know
i would be in trouble and many of these
people are trouble and then i would look
at funny people and look at successful
people and i'd be in a blind rage which
is where these people live
they've wasted their entire life i hate
using a hack example
i hate using a hack example i'm gonna
use a dumb hack example again that i've
used a million times
but if i showed up every day to
ford modeling agency someone there would
have to sit me down and go
explain to us why you think this is
gonna work
explain to us what you're seeing in the
world
that makes you think that we want a
blotchy
overweight irishman in any of our ads
we want mediterranean muscle baby
black white whatever don't care why do
you think this is going to work
nowhere in our in our pre do we want
redness
occasional redness unexplained
redness i don't even know why it happens
i just get
red in parts of my body my skin my
emotions bleed out of my skin
these people are going to ford modeling
and i don't even know who this is and
i'm sure they're not a horrible person
and would
i don't care this is not like beefs and
feuds it doesn't matter to me maybe they
are funny
no but let's not leave this up i don't
want to [ __ ] look at this [ __ ]
article
let's let's get something fun up like a
jack-o-lantern
but the whole thing here is be very very
very
be very honest here
is a little bit of the anger jealousy
that joe has done something that none of
these people were able to do
these people think they're intelligent
and they're smart
and and they're too good to have the
biggest podcast in the world they're too
smart they're too smart
to have the biggest podcast in the world
what a take
they're too good for success me and
mullen used to talk about that all the
time
people are too good to succeed they're
too funny
to perform in front of other people
they're too good
so the rage that these people live with
all all the time they're just angry
they're just very very angry that
they've dedicated their life
to something that hasn't worked out and
here's the quest
here's the quest who told you
to do that who
told you that that was a good idea i bet
no one did no when you go to
thanksgiving you go i'm a comedian your
family goes thanks
great peel the potato no one cares
imagine going to your family going i'm a
comedy journalist
this is a million people who want to be
chapel trap house you're not
they are very very funny they're
hilarious whatever you think about their
chat and they talk [ __ ] about everybody
but they're very funny you know i don't
even know who they are
but whatever they mullin live with one
of them the skinny woman with the cat
i i think they're good i they're funny
and then there's 90 million other people
and then the red people are funny too
red uh the
the communist [ __ ] i don't know
whatever that show is scary they're good
too they're funny right some of them i
don't know but occasionally i've heard
things like i like it
uh whatever i don't mind i don't mind
little marxism baby
but then there's 90 million [ __ ]
people that aren't funny
that are just angry because things are
unfair
that i'm oh yes things are not good
did i do i come out here every week and
go it's it's getting better
and lives what am i ben shapiro well
actually folks it's actually not as bad
as you think
no i think i'm pretty honest about how
[ __ ] we are
and if you think that the reason we're
[ __ ] is alex jones man are you out to
[ __ ] lunch how lucky would we be
how lucky would we be if the biggest
problem in this country was some
it's like a conspiracy guy in texas
that's crazy
the problems are so institutional so
deep rooted
that this selective rage and a
successful podcast
having a guy on a broadcaster and then
fact checking him in real [ __ ] time
i mean that's crazy that you would get
so angry about that but it's it's really
about
just the rick because they never were
cool they just want to be
they just want to throw eggs with johnny
and alfred
well i don't know there johnny came to
see me in west palm beach by the way
thank you for coming
i didn't let him in the green room as a
coven i love that now because it covered
i got no one could come in the green
room because of covert
the manager can't talk to me because
they're covered uh uh uh
my f no i don't have a next of kin clove
it
go to the doctor that you're gonna fill
out that next to kin i just write
covered they're all dead
ridge wallet
ridge wallet is a wallet and it is metal
and you sanitize it easily and it is
thirty thousand five star reviews
they have partnered with this show for a
long time ridge wallet is a phenomenal
product
it is sleek it is sharp you put it in
your front
pocket nobody knows you have it nobody's
going to rob you they don't see a big
bulging thing
if they want to see a bulge you know
what i'm talking about it's not going to
be your wallet it's going to be your hog
ridge wallet is a spectacular way
to pare down a lot of the unnecessary
[ __ ]
you keep in your wallet all the time
i'm telling you right i don't know how
else to advertise this while i i don't
know i'll tell you a story
that might drive home the f a friend of
mine
thought about getting a ridge wallet
he thought about it he thought long and
hard he decided
not to get him
and you know what happened to him what
why are you asking like that
you're asking like you're not really
interested no i am very
asking you a lot you're asking that
you're asking like you're not interested
in what happened to my friend when he
made the tragic
mistake of of not getting a rich wallet
you know what happened what happened to
him his
children and this is in the news you can
look it up his
own children
killed him do you know how old they were
how old two and four and they killed
their father
you know how they did it yeah they lit
him on fire while he slapped
and you know what they said when they
were asked why they did it what
he didn't get a ridge wallet and you
know what the state did not press
charges
and the wife said i will get another
father who's smarter
she didn't care
even as the smell of his burnt corpse
was in her nostrils she said he should
have made a better decision
if you like my show if you like
podcasting
if you like comedy if you like wallets
if you like other people and want to
give them gifts
if you want to do this as a bit if you
want to play a practical joke and get
these wallets all i want you to do
is go to ridge.com timtimridge.com and
use the code tim the link is in the
description
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping it returns when you
when you support the products you
support the program
and we really truly appreciate that
thank you very much i love raycon i lost
my earbuds the other day and i said am i
going to pay 300
for new apple ipod air potty papoopa
no what do they call them your buds your
pods pod
airpods pair pods they [ __ ] you
raycon is the best six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass
more compact design and noise isolating
fit
they're used by people like snoop dogg
melissa etheridge brandy
mike tyson rich the kid
okay raycon has a 45 day
free return posse but nobody cares
nobody used nobody does it because they
love them
this is a from a syringe from a video
that's coming out
it's in my pocket there's syringes all
over the house
and had to go into a store and get a
bunch of syringes and they're like
looking at him like what
and then ben had to go listen i'm not a
diabetic i'm doing a sketch
how many did you buy 10. if i want you
to get 10 syringes they go how about 30.
10 can't be enough how about 30. people
just start injecting me in the store
raycon is the best i mean these are
these are great uh headphones
am i wrong amazing so much better than
the airpods
i agree yeah they're wireless
they're cool people go hey let's do it a
conversation should be like
you're an attractive woman i'm a guy and
and i you know what what are those are
those
airpods oh my god can i ask you what are
those are those airpods
um they're raycon you stupid [ __ ]
why did you think they were air pods
they're black they're a different color
okay i'm sorry i just i just thought
they were white they were just sticking
out i thought it was air pods or
something i don't know
yeah why don't you start paying
attention to your surroundings before
you get thrown in a van
oh god you understand that
oh my god well the greatest thing about
these things they don't cost a lot of
money get the same thing
it's the same thing spending more money
for what you
you know they're premium wireless
earbuds
you could get them less than half the
price of airpods
for a limited time get 15 off your order
at buy ratecon.com tim that's
buyredcon.com
tim for 15 discount on raycon wireless
earbuds make sure to check it out now
while the deal is running by raycon.com
tim but did everybody wants to throw
eggs
everybody wants to to
put shaving cream on the car it's what
it is
people aren't thinkers these people
aren't
actualized human beings they want a hug
they want someone to go you're you
matter you're
valid you you you're you're
you should be here and i mean on earth
hey you should be here on this planet
that's
all these people are trying to do and
don't think
anything of it you think alex jones is
changing minds
the joe rogan experience you think my
aunt who's a hardcore biden voter is
gonna go well
you know alex made a good point about
inter-dimensional
uh lizards so i think i'm going to go in
there and vote red
no this whole thing of people
influencing each other it's like
there's such a small sliver of people
that can even be influenced
you know and alex is more is a complex
guy
smart guy made some mistakes very clear
but this whole blind rage that everybody
flies into every time joe has a
conversation
with people they don't like is is
embarrassing i'm embarrassed for a lot
of these people i'm like
why have you not like
figured out that you're the entire
problem
the entire reason you know the red scare
at steve bannon on people went nuts they
got mad
they got angry why why
they're having a conversation what's
dangerous about having a conversation
i don't understand it's but it goes back
to just social i get you know i get i
get it's it's you learn all those
lessons young
if you pay attention you learn all those
lessons young you people just want to be
uh accepted they want to accept each
other they just want to be and all these
people just want to be a revolution they
just want to it's not it's got to matter
right
it's got to matter can all be shitty job
interviews in panera let me throw a
brick through the [ __ ] louis vuitton
and let's do a little revolution i'm
bored
can't all be broccoli and cheese soup on
the way to some hell
i want a revolution i want to i want i
want to live in historic times
i want to do something well then do
something do something actually
something
and i'm not saying you know don't
[ __ ] i know that comfort is showing
but you know what i'm saying like create
something
help people help someone and don't do
that
go go ask any of these people if they
volunteer their suitcase they'll look
you like uh
you you have 10 heads
you know i know people that go i don't
like comedians that go to like
a help the homeless workshop they all
see each other and then they never help
the homeless
what is a help the homeless workshop by
the way can anyone explain to me what
that even is
so [ __ ] hipster and echo park being
like what we really should do is be
working
can you imagine some homeless guy who's
like mentally ill
who's done three tours in iraq he unzips
um
he unzips uh his tent and like brandon
wardell's there with a clipboard like
hey man can you get and i love brandon
but you know what i mean
like what what is that the solution
what are we talking about paul f
tompkins is gonna walk around
under bridges and help the homeless can
we get real
amy man's gonna be there with a guitar
sorry you're homeless
sorry you're harmless doesn't it suck
i i'm and i'm at fault somehow i'm at
fault
and i like brandon brendan what's his
name brandon brandon brandon yeah
i'm kidding with him i know i like him i
like them all
i have no problems with anyone
people don't like me
huh what's that
odd very strange
i don't understand have i said things in
the past would lead people to
uh dislike me probably probably have i
been wrong
no that should matter
shouldn't that matter i said sanders was
a good idea
people got mad at me for that i think
healthcare is my mother's
a mental institution uh that's run by
the state uh you want to talk about a
horror movie
and they still can't find a way to kill
her we're paying good money
christ almighty if we lose this covert
window to get rid of this [ __ ] we'll
never do it
she'll live forever
i think it's a great idea if my aunt
wasn't a saint and didn't work her ass
off getting my mother into that hospital
there would be my mother might be
homeless okay
that is why i said sanders was good
because i believe that people that are
mentally ill
especially the people that have served
the country or whatever should not be
allowed to die in the streets
that is what i believe that position
is apparently alt-right
i was willing to vote for bernie sanders
i'm not voting this time because i don't
know how to vote
i don't have a voting plan my business
manager called me goes
should you should we register you in
california i said will you leave me
alone
go vote it looks gross
have you seen it have you seen these
people voting
they look sad and desperate
i don't want to go to libraries and
firehouses
let's go to dinner if my friend called
me and said are we gonna go vote i said
why don't we just go to dinner
i think me and my friends went to vote
once we just went to dinner
yeah cares the line's too long
i got us a table let's go have a few
laughs we're all dead tomorrow we're
dead now
here's the funny thing we're dead now
i mean california is not a swing state
i don't want to vote for trump and i
don't want to vote for joe biden
and uh you know uh calamari harris i
don't want to be involved in in any of
that
so what they could start a war with
north korea and russia in five months to
prove a point
and nothing could get any [ __ ] better
or we're going to vote for trump again
who's now talking about jesus because he
knows it's almost over
did you see that clip today the trump
jesus clip pull that up
this is a guy the only time he's been in
the church is when he got married
[ __ ] nine times here we go and it's a
tricky
thing it's uh it's dust it's a little
tricky thing
masks no mess everything you can do all
you want but you know
you still need help from the boss
we need help from the boss that's what
happened
we need help
i love and you got to love him what a
con what a was it for man
what a con i mean forever and all things
and i can't there's a soft spot in my
heart for a huckster
there's a soft spot in my heart for a
connor
he is standing there he's at the end and
he might be losing and he might not be
but he's just like
the great khan is always the first con
and it's
christ it's god it's jesus it's the
it's with the all good con artists go
back to that first con at the end
they all go to jesus at the end and
that's the truly poetic
thing about trump here is you are
watching somebody
at the end of a long con that has been
more successful than any other
it makes enron look like nothing
i mean this is truly a thing to watch
and let's watch this you know
it's all right to say now they'll
criticize me for that how dare he say
that
how dare he say that no i'll say it i'll
say it
i'll say it somebody said to me the
other day you're the most famous person
in the world by far i said no i'm not
no i'm not they said yes you are said no
i said who's more famous i said jesus
christ
yeah it feels like it's almost over it
kind of does
i'm not taking any chances i'm not going
to have a dog
hey i'm not having any arguments
jesus christ i'm not going to take any
chances house give it i
guarantee and let me look up and i'll
say and it's not even close
if he goes down and he will maybe i mean
that's what the numbers say but he also
may not right
uh if he he will be
the funnest post president he'll have
the funnest post-presidency
they'll have him on all the shows
they'll have them on all the chat shows
hollywood will embrace him they'll all
embrace him
they'll all embrace him because they
just want to win they want to win at a
small
game a petty game and as soon as he's
gone they'll do what they did with
george w bush it might take a while he
might die before it can fully happen
but if he's still around and he might be
he's
figured out something that works
mcchickens and adderalls i don't know
what he does but it's fine he figures it
out
um they will have him on he'll go on
he'll goof around he'll be funny he'll
go back to being a celebrity
he'll go back to being uh hollywood
and uh and everybody will just be okay
with that
everybody will be okay with it because
they don't really care
they don't really care um
and it'll just be it'll be fun to see
right because they they will have
they will have then done it they will
have gone and thrown eggs with johnny
and alfred on halloween night and they
will have gotten it out of their system
they will have gotten it out of their
system they said we shave and cream the
cars
and we threw all the eggs and all the
popular kids hung out we all roamed
together
we all roamed together in one pack and
nobody stood out too much
and it was just fun it was just fun
because for
from a moment i felt like i mattered
and and i and i i did the thing that i
came to do
right and there's all these people when
he when he loses if he loses
that's what uh will happen i believe i
believe that the hysteria
will calm down um i believe that
you know or may not it may intensify and
increase i mean we are you know who the
[ __ ] knows what will happen but
when you see him there and he's in his
element he's with these people he's so
funny he's so on his game
um you know he will he doesn't care
to a great con doesn't get invested you
dummies oh he cares about
there are things he cares about i'm sure
but a great khan like he is
you know like a guy who
truly is you know
a craven narcissist a megalomaniac
uh you know he's up there and he's
basically
saying it's me in christ that's what
that whole thing is because it's me
and that should almost be the last thing
he says it's the perfect coda to it
yeah there's one guy bigger than me and
it's jesus
and i don't want to take any chances
there's one guy bigger than me
because in he's right he's not
wrong to his people and at this moment
and at this moment in history he is the
biggest
other than jesus you did it
donald you did it you threw all the eggs
you shave and creamed all the car
there's nothing left to do
there's nothing left to do you did it
you made
all of the [ __ ] deals that you didn't
make and who cares anyway
you know you made the big deal which is
the deal
with your people your followers
your fans your rock star you're a rock
star
the second term will barely be fun
you're not going to get anything done
that god only knows you did it you
had kind of the rock star presidency you
can always blame the economy and
you wouldn't be wrong to say the economy
crashed because of covet
say i was rocking out and then coveted
came and [ __ ] man
yeah the second album never happened but
that first album
man that was a good one that first album
was billy joel the stranger or whatever
in the 70s or whatever you know that was
the big one that was
you know that was the one that we we're
still playing the hits
billy joel's still playing the hits
isn't he he's still playing those hits
and donald you can you can still go play
the hits you can still do the rallies
you can still have the fun you can still
be
this massive force and and if this is
this may be
do we have another one coming out before
the election no
well patreon yeah join that
um but this may be
the last episode where donald trump is
president yeah yeah
and i will say this as someone who who's
always who knows what he is and there's
no uh
i've no i understand what he's doing so
i'm not taking in like many of you into
this emotional
you spiral many of you will spiral when
biden wins i will wake up and go man
and vice versa but many of you will
spiral because you are children and
we've talked about this many times and
yet telling your children does not get
you to not act like them
um and it's because it's [ __ ] that's
what like if you turn around and go
you're a child what does a kid do do
they start there they straighten up and
go you're right now they go
doesn't work i've tried um
but i will say this this man
emerged in 2016
um he's done some very bad things
some good ones some that
and a lot of nothing you know so somehow
a lot of
like nothing right um but i will say
this
it has driven the people in my business
to the brink of insanity and then some
it has driven those people
insane it has rendered them ineffective
and useless and it is paved the way
for people like me and and the other
people that i mentioned in the show the
chapos and the whoevers of the world
to really [ __ ] look at our business
for what it is
which was also a con for many for a very
long time
and one con exposed another khan and if
donald trump
has done nothing else but destroy
the facade of hollywood and
he does nothing else other than that and
to pull the cover back
on on the corporate media and hollywood
then hey you did it
you did something you know you truly did
something
because they don't matter anymore
these people they don't matter no one
cares
i live here i know that no one cares
and if that's the only thing that trump
was able to accomplish
you know and he asked the kids in the
cages obama had him there he didn't care
that he cared now
it was bad when he did it bad when trump
did it bad bad bad get an immigration
policy can't let everybody in
to press his wages it's again we pass
this we'll pass it we all know you don't
care you don't care what the facts are
it doesn't matter
on both sides you don't care what the
fact nobody cares right so
what am i going to do with the data
we're going to put the graph up
what are we going to do we know this
immigration shouldn't be an emotional
issue
do we need more immigrants do we not
what's unemployment look like what's
inequality look like
what do do people have health care do
they have anything should we be
importing low-wage labor unskilled labor
at this moment right now
more of it less of it it's a gradient
it's you know but whatever nobody cares
i'm not going to care aoc is a vanity
fair man
stop it she's throwing eggs
i don't want to throw eggs so
but i will say that's the enduring
legacy of trump to me
the enduring legacy uh trump to me is it
took a guy
from hollywood to break everybody's
minds
because he used their system against
them he weaponized the structures that
they had created
the obsession with celebrities the
narcissism the vulgarity the
vanity the ugliness he
turned it on its head
he made it cool he wanted
to be the president and he found a way
to do it
using twitter from his toilet he
took your value system
and ran with it he became
the best version of you
he took all of the things that you
believed in
that you worshipped and that you
idolized
and he used them to defeat you he didn't
do it with knowledge
he didn't do it with hard work he didn't
do it with
you know faith he didn't do it with
competence he did it with vanity
vulgarity narcissism he did it with
cheap and he took
it and he sold it back
to you right
yes or yes that's what happened
so don't be mad
benjamin franklin once said
don't hate the player hate the game
and there's a lot of people in this
country
that think that the only problems are
the players
it's just the players it's just that
conspiracy theorists we don't like on
rogan it's just that game show host who
became president
but it is the game a little bit isn't it
and it's it's all of us
it's just all of us right it's it's kind
of the
folly of humanity at the end of the day
it's why i like halloween
i like halloween because it makes people
pretend for a day that all of the
horrors
are fake and that we can control them
we have power on halloween
we dress up and we decide what haunted
house to go to
and we like to get scared and spooked
in a controlled environment and we like
to have
fun on halloween that's why i've always
liked halloween
it's simulating something that
really terrifies us down deep it's a
simulation of something
and when donald trump took office in
the simulation won
good night